[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كان يا مكان حكايه بحكيها لكم اليوم عن
طفله صغيره ولدت عام 2004 كانت اول فرحه
لاسرتها عائله محبه مهتمه داعمه واعيه
وبالتاكيد حانيه كبرت بطله قصتي في بي
ارائ جدا منميه لذاتها وكيانها ومستمتعه
بكل لحظات طفولتها من لعب ومرح
وتعليم بالتحديد في عام
2013 في كرسيها وطاولت في احد حصه العلوم
جت معلمه بيدها ظرف في نظر تلك الصغيره
هذا الظرف مره عملاق بكل وضوح وثبات تكرر
على مسامعها لا تفتحيها خلي الماما او
البابا يفتحوها معك اوكي ما كان عل عليها
الا انها تهز راسها بالموافقه وتمنع
فضولها وخوفها القليل من هذا الظرف اتوقع
كلكم تتسائلون عن محتوى هذا الظرف كانت
كلمات بسيطه لبدايه تجربه جديده ومغامره
جديده لهذه الفتاه واحساس بكامل الفخر من
قبل اهل البنت بان بنتهم كبرت فلتم زها
فلقد تم ترشيح ابنتكم للقيام باختبار
مقياس موهبه المقدم من مؤسسه الملك عبد
العزيز رجاله للموهبه والابداع موهبه خاض
ذات التسع سنوات هذا الاختبار دعم وتشجيع
وامال لكن للاسف ما حالفها الحظ انها تفتح
باب تجربتها الجديد انتهت السنه وجت اجاده
الصيف شهر كامل خارج المملكه اجازه وترفيه
مع الماما والبابا واختها رزان اللي
تصغرها بسنه هنا تجارب مستمره تتعلم كيف
تواجه الامور تاخذ مسؤوليه كونها الكبيره
وتقوي اللغه الانجليزيه
حقتها على هذا المنوال من اهتمام متفوق
دين جا عام
2016 قررت مره ثانيه انها تخوض تجربتها
اللي ما قدرت تفتحها بشكل كويس خاضت
الاختبار مع تركيزها على هذا الهدف فعلا
حصلت على الدرجه اللي تاهل بانها تكون
ابنه لموهبه تلك المؤسسه العظيمه اللي
خدمت واعطى ومستمره في هذا
العطاء في بعد ما انتهت عام 2016 تخرجت من
المرحله المتوسطه وعزمت بكل اصرار انها
تجرب كل الفرص الموجوده والمتاحه لها في
المرحله الثانويه طبعا خلال اجازه الصيف
والسنوات السابقه من انضمامها لموهبه كان
في برامج ودورات ورش عمل ومغامرات حتى
توسيع مدارك معرفيه لتلك الصغيره كان
دائما لسان حالها يقول حس اني شفت المكان
اللي انتمي له ففعلا موهبه حيث ننتمي
وتنتمي عزمت وبكل اصرار انها تجرب الفرص
في مرحلتها الثانويه كون هالمرحله الاحلى
من دراسه الشخص بطبيعه الاحوال في عام 20
20 تكرر السيناريو مره ثانيه كانت جالسه
في كرسيها وطاولت في احد فصول الموهبه تم
الاعلان عن مسابقه زي اي مسابقه موجوده
ذهلت وتسرع وسجلت في الاولمبياد الوطني
للابداع العلمي ولان من موهبه فبالتاكيد
بتشارك خلال اسبوعين بس عرفت عن محتوى هذه
المسابقه وانهم يبغون بحث علمي او ابتكار
او حتى اختراع بلمسه جديده لا باحث ولا
دكتور ولا حتى بروفيسور قد سواها من قبل
سلمت و وخلصت امورها كلها واو وا قها لين
حست انها فعلا سوت اللي هي تبغى تسويه بس
كانت خايفه هل بتكمل والله لا بعد فتره
انشغال ظهرت النتائج وللاسف ما كان حليف
هالحظ في
الاكمال فشل هي الكلمه الوحيده اللي حست
فيها هذه البنت في ذيك اللحظه ولكن زي ما
يقولوا تستمر الحياه
كورونا جائحه اغلقت مدارس مدن عالم اغلقت
جميع الفرص البيبان كلها تسكرت اتوقع انه
كان في احباط وجهل
بالقادم وهذه الاحاسيس ما رافقت بس بطلت
قصتي اتوقع رافقت الجميع صح ولا
لا استوعبت ان المسابقه سنويه فيمد انها
تعدل اخطائها خلال هذه الاجازه اللي ما
ادري متى
بتخلص وتشارك في برامج ودورات ممكن
تساعدها لقت برنامج من مبادره لطلاب قد
خاضوا هذه التجربه وفازوا مثل دوله
دوليا ساعدوها اثنوا عليها البرنامج كان
لمده ثلاث شهور هي خلصت في شهر واحد لانها
اصلا بدات في المشروع من قبل جءت النسخه
الجديده سجلت وخلصت امورها وكل لها يقين
هذه المره انها فعلا حتوصل للمرحله الجايه
وكانت على قد كلامها وعلى قد ايمانها
تاهلت على مستوى المنطقه
الشرقيه
جاتها لحظه ادراك ما في اي مختص يكمل معها
المشروع والتجارب العلميه الكل فعليا
يواجه ويحاول انه يحارب هذه الجائحه اللي
قاعده تصير فشل
مجددا كسر هذا الاحساس بصوت حاني جدا بابا
انا موجود هنا
بساعدك كملت مشروعها وزادت شمعه الامل
فيها لين جاء البريد الالكتروني اللي يقول
مبارك تاهل لواحد من افضل 150 مشروع علمي
على مستوى
المملكه اكبر تجمع بحثي هل هي فعليا في هل
هي من افضل الطلاب في المملكه شعور جميل
جدا شعور بالانجاز والفخر وما كانت الوحيد
اللي تحس بهذا الشعور جميع من حولها يحسون
بهذا الشيء ايضا اسبوع د من هذه الفرحه
لين انخطفت بشكل مفاجئ للشخص
الحاني الشخص اللي كان سبب في اشعال شمعه
الامل تلك اب
بطلتي ضعف الم عدم
تصديق ضعف شديد كل اللي كانت تعرفه ان
ايام الله باقدار قاعده تمشي كروتين بفرض
دائم ماما ابوك ما ما يبغى يشوفكم كذا
يبيكم تستمرون عشانه دفعت نهوض من ام
بطلتي لها والاخت رزان تفكرت في هذه
الكلمات واستوعبت انه فعلا اللي خلف ما
مات لازم تكون هي القدوه الحسنه لها
وخواتها خصوصا اختها الصغيره اللي تصغرها
ب 12 سنه اقدار الله وارزاق انهالت عليها
بذيك الفتره قدرت تكمل مشروعها تنشر علمها
تساعد الطلاب التائهين اللي كانت زيهم في
يوم من الايام في برامج ودورات مختلفه
تتذكرون المبادره اللي ساعدتها عشان تعدل
مشروعها هي كانت فعليا طالبه تتلقى العلم
ولكن اصبحت احد
مدربيها في 2022 قبل ما تتخرج صديقتنا من
المرحله الثانويه رشحت لتمثيل الدوله
والمملكه في مسابقه ايتكس الدوليه
للاختراعات والابتكارات والتقنيه
حصلت على المركز الاول بميداليه ذهبيه
بنفس مشروعها المستمر من 20 20 ليومنا
هذا بطله قصتي هي انا
ريما اسمي ريما يوسف ال يوسف ابلغ 18 سنه
من المنطقه الشرقيه ابن ل موهبه من 2016
وطالبه طب بشري في كليات الرؤيه الصحيه
الابنه الكبرى لعائلتي واخت لرزان ويمنى
فقت والدي المهندس يوسف سعيد ال يوسف قبل
عامين من الان فجعت بخبير بخبر رحيل ابو
الموهوبين الدكتور نزيه العثماني قبل شهور
من الان فقدان رحيل ضعف الم غربه فشل نجاح
هذا هذا الشعور مو بس انا اللي حسيت فيها
الكل ممكن يحس بهذه المشاعر باختلاف
الظروف العبره من حديثي هذا استمرارنا لنا
لذاتنا لوطننا ولتلك الاجساد التي رحلت
وظلت اعمالهم موجوده وارواحهم موجوده
فخرهم لنا موجود املهم موجود نحن في وطن
طموح وطن معطاء وطن فيه الكثير من الفرص
والايمان بنا نحن الشباب علينا ان نستمر
لنعمر هذه الدنيا عشان نشيد بوطنا عاليا
كما هو
دوما ان لم تفشل فانت لم تحاول ابدا عليك
ان تفشل لتتعلم
لتنجح هكذا ستترك اثر شكرا
[تصفيق]
لكم
[موسيقى]
ن